S
VISIT AND WHAT THE PRESIDENT
ACCOMPLISHED AS THE ANNIVERSARY
OF RUSSIA'S INVASION OF UKRAINE
APPROACHES.
>>> MEANTIME THE ALL BUT
DECLARED CANDIDACY OF DeSANTIS,
DeSANTIS' OPERATION GOT A $2.5
MILLION CHECK FROM ONE DONOR AND
A MILLION DOLLAR APIECE FOR ONE
MORE.
THIS COMES AS THE PRESIDENT'S
CAMPAIGN STYLE STOPS.
THIS WEEKEND HE'S SCHEDULED TO
HOST A THREE-DAY DONOR RETREAT
FROM THE PRESIDENT'S MAR-A-LAGO
ESTATE.
AND NEXT WEEK A NEW MEMOIR COMES
OUT FOLLOWED BY A FUTURE BOOK
TOUR.
JOINED NOW BY HARRY ENTEN WITH
MORE.
DOES IT SURPRISE YOU DeSANTIS IS
GETTING THESE BIG CHECKS WITHOUT
EVEN ANNOUNCING THEM?
>> I'M NOT SURPRISED AT ALL,
ANDERSON.
THE REASON I'M NOT SURPRISED AT
ALL LOOK HOW MUCH MONEY HE
RAISED DURING HIS 2022
RE-ELECTION BID FOR FLORIDA
GOVERNOR.
NORTH OF $200 MILLION.
NORTH OF $200 MILLION, AND LOOK
AT HOW MUCH TRUMP RAISED IN
ESSENTIALLY THE FIRST MONTH AND
HALF OF HIS CAMPAIGN ENDING AT
THE END OF 2022, ONLY ABOUT $10
MILLION, IN FACT A LITTLE BIT
LESS THAN THAT.
MONEY ISN'T EVERYTHING IN
POLITICS IN A PRESIDENTIAL BID,
BUT YOU CAN'T HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
CAMPAIGN WITHOUT HAVING MONEY ON
HAND.
>> HE'S BEEN VIEWED AS A
NATIONAL CANDIDATE OR POTENTIAL
NATIONAL CANDIDATE FOR QUITE A
WHILE.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT, AND
THAT'S WHY I THINK HE RAISED SO
MUCH IN 2022 BECAUSE THERE WERE
A LOT OF PEOPLE TRYING AGAIN IN
ROUND FOUR, RIGHT, SO TO ME THIS
IS AN
>> JUST IN TERMS OF POLLS, HE'S
ALREADY ON THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S HEELS, ISN'T HE?
>> HE'S VERY MUCH SO.
WE HAD TWO PRETTY GOOD NATIONAL
POLLS THAT CAME OUT IN THE LAST
FEW WEEKS.
ONE FROM QUINNIPIAC AND ONE FROM
MA MOTH.
YOU SEE DeSANTIS UP TO 36%.
YOU SEE ANOTHER ONE --
>> LOOK AT HALEY AND PENCE.
>> WAY BACK.
THERE WAS ALL THIS THOUGHT, OH,
MY GOD, ALL THESE CANDIDATES
WILL GET IN AND IT MIGHT SPLIT
THE ANTI-TRUMP VOTE, RIGHT?
BUT HERE IS WHAT I WANT TO TELL
YOU, ANDERSON.
IF YOU TAKE ONE THING AWAY FROM
ME, IT IS THIS.
>> I WANT TO TAKE ONE THING.
>> I HOPE YOU WANT TO TAKE TWO
OR THREE THINGS AWAY FROM ME.
BUT EITHER WAY, IF YOU TAKE ONE
THING AWAY FROM ME, IT'S THAT
THE ANTI-TRUMP VOTE THIS HERE IS
NOT SPLIT AS MUCH AS IT WAS IN
2016.
DeSANTIS AT THIS POINT WITH 36%,
33% OF THE VOTE, IT IS A LIST
ESSENTIALLY AT THIS POINT THREE
MONTHS AFTER TRUMP DECLARED
DURING HIS 2016 BID, THE TOP
LEADING CANDIDATE WAS BEN CARSON
WHO WAS ONLY 17% IN QUINNIPIAC'S
POLL.
AT THIS POINT MUCH HIGHER.
>> WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU SEE
THEM ONE-ON-ONE?
>> YOU SEE DeSANTIS JUMP OUT
AHEAD.
DONALD TRUMP AT 40%.
SO I THINK THE IDEA ESSENTIALLY
IS IF, IN FACT, RON DeSANTIS
GETS INTO A ONE-ON-ONE WITH
TRUMP, THAT'S MAJOR TROUBLE FOR
THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> IS THERE EVIDENCE THAT TRUMP
IS NO LONGER AS POPULAR AS HE
WAS?
>> LOOK.
WE SAID TRUMP HAD THIS 80%
APPROVAL RATING.
NO ONE HAS A HIGHER APPROVAL
RATING WITH DONALD TRUMP.
BUT LOOK AT THE NET FAVORABILITY
RATINGS.
LOOK AT RAN DeSANTIS ON YOUR
SCREEN RIGHT NOW.
WHERE IS HE?
HE'S PLUS -- INTO THE 70s.
LOOK AT WHERE DONALD TRUMP IS.
BELOW THAT.
SO THE FACT IS AT THIS
PARTICULAR POINT DONALD TRUMP
ISN'T THE MOST POPULAR
CANDIDATE.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
MUCH ABOUT RON DeSAN